Kuei, bienvenue à Parole autochtone,
ici c'est Melissa Mollen Dupuis.
Cette semaine, on a reçu une question
de Betsy, qu'on va écouter :
« Comment est-ce que les communautés autochtones peuvent s'y prendre afin d'intégrer les médias
et prendre leur place
dans les médias au Québec? »
Merci Betsy. Alors, comment est-ce que
les Premières Nations peuvent prendre
leur place dans les médias du Québec?
C'est plutôt comment les médias
du Québec peuvent-ils laisser de la place
aux Autochtones et aux communautés
qui font partie aussi d'une diversité
de cultures et de nations?
Je pense que ça doit venir d'une
volonté, mais aussi je pense, des fois,
il faut que ça vienne du public.
Une volonté des organismes, une volonté
des médias, mais une volonté du public
de vouloir avoir quelque chose de nouveau,
d'avoir une voix qui est peut-être pas celle
que tu reconnais, parce qu'on peut mettre
des Premières Nations devant les caméras,
mais si les gens
ne les écoutent pas, c'est sûr
qu'à un moment donné, ils vont se faire tasser
pour une émission plus populaire,
pour un animateur ou une animatrice qui vont
peut-être répondre plus à des semblants culturels
ou à des visages plus connus.
Donc, il faut être ouvert à, des fois,
se faire surprendre et même des fois
se faire surprendre par la langue.
Parce qu'il ne faut pas oublier
que pour les Premières Nations, souvent le français
et l'anglais, ce sont des langues secondes.
Quand on apprend
une nouvelle langue,
l'accent de la langue innue, l'accent de la langue crie
va ressortir et ça peut être un blocage
pour avoir accès à des emplois
devant les caméras.
Mais c'est de s'intéresser, aussi, aux nouvelles
qui viennent des communautés
parce que si vous voulez avoir des Premières Nations
dans les médias, c'est que vous voulez
entendre la voix des Premières Nations
et le message qui vient avec.
Donc, c'est l'histoire et le vécu des communautés.
Alors, Betsy, je pense que, déjà, le fait
que te poses la question,
le fait que ça t'intéresse, c'est déjà une grande
ouverture pour que les communautés
viennent dans ton salon, viennent
dans tes journaux et, d'ailleurs, c'est pour ça
qu'on vous invite à nous envoyer
des questions, à partager les vidéos, aussi,
pour commencer à piquer l'intérêt
du public québécois, et même canadien, parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de Canadiens qui sont francophones
en dehors des limites
de la province du Québec.
Donc, merci encore Betsy pour ta question.
N'hésitez pas à partager le vidéo.
N'hésitez pas non plus à nous envoyer
vos questions à Espaces autochtones.
Bonne semaine!